[Musica]
senza dati sei solo un altra persona con
un opinione quante volte avete sentito
questa citazione è una frase
dell'ingegnere manager statunitense
william edward hemmings vissuto nel
secolo scorso
e se si prova a cercarla in un motore di
ricerca si ottengono ben 16 milioni di
risultati viene usata in tutti gli
ambiti dalle aziende alle istituzioni
per contrapporre i dati solidi rigorosi
affidabili alle opinioni volubili
soggettive suscettibili alle mozioni
sembra sensato no
vi racconto una storia di dati che mi
riguarda qualche anno fa sono stata in
messico a trovare la mia amica the
rasmus stefani e ho deciso che avrei
provato a quantificare il mio viaggio
oltre che a godermi cibo avventure e
spiagge e nuotate con gli squali balena
ecco cosa è venuto fuori grazie a un
braccialetto contapassi che ho indossato
ogni giorno nel grafico si vedono i siti
archeologici più grandi e impegnativi
che abbiamo visitato ma si può notare
anche che in una giornata passata al
centro commerciale di la isla a cancun e
poi perdendosi nei terminal
dell'aeroporto si può camminare più che
nelle rovine di un altro sito
archeologico quello di tulum è stato un
esperimento interessante mi è piaciuto
leggere i dati dei miei movimenti e
quando ho cominciato ad allenarmi per la
mia prima maratona ho comprato un gps
più sofisticato che mi permettesse di
raccogliere i dati sulla corsa secondo
l'up collegata all'orologio
in quell'anno di duri allenamenti avevo
percorso solo 25 km in media settimana
non era possibile quindi ho di nuovo
visualizzato i dati raggiunto delle note
nei mesi in cui secondo l'up ero stata
più scarsa
ero stata un'ottima atleta in realtà
tranne per alcuni giustificati stop
comprensibili solo aggiunge
dettagli di cosa mi era successo in quei
dodici mesi un'influenza un viaggio in
senegal una caviglia slogata si vede già
dove voglio arrivare
cominciamo a parlare di limiti perché i
dati ci raccontano solo una parte della
storia quella che decido di contare di
quantificare e visualizzare il resto
però il contesto è altrettanto
importante
andiamo avanti c'è comunque un altra
cosa utile che possono fare i dati
metterci di fronte a quello che non
riusciamo a capire quando siamo convinti
delle nostre percezioni di quello che
conosciamo già o su cui abbiamo
esperienza hanno anche il potere di
rivelare quello che non possiamo vedere
perché magari non ci riguarda
ecco cosa intendo dire nella giornata
mondiale contro la violenza sulle donne
il 25 novembre ho disegnato una mappa
per raccontare cosa vuol dire uscire di
casa
preoccupandosi di non passeggiare o
correre per strade isolate avere un
cappotto abbastanza lungo da coprire il
sedere se di prendere la metropolitana i
mezzi pubblici
il cellulare sempre carico o le chiavi
di casa ben stretta in mano è comunque
una mappa disegnata da una donna che
vive in un contesto abbastanza sicuro
io sono fortunata le mie crocette sono
soltanto tre ma quante ne avrebbero
messe attorno alla loro casa le 38 donne
uccise da mariti e compagni quest'anno
siamo due femminicidi a settimana o chi
lavora in un ufficio dove le molestie
sessiste sono all'ordine del giorno
o ancora come sarebbe questa mappa ma
disegnata da un adolescente che vive in
india il paese più pericoloso per le
donne
secondo una classifica della thomson
reuters foundation del 2018
questa mappa ha il merito di rendere
visibili situazioni di cui non ci
saremmo mai resi conto prima se non
vissute in prima persona come per
esempio il fatto che per una donna anche
praticare sport è un'attività pericolosa
o soggetta a restrizioni di libertà
quando deve scegliere l'ora o il luogo
in cui allena
farsi i dati mettono in fila esperienze
personali aneddoti casi che ci sembrano
isolati e smettono di esserlo quando
iniziano a contare
avete mai visto cars il cartone animato
e di disney pixar in cui una macchinina
di nome saetta mcqueen deve vincere la
prestigiosa piston cup durante una corsa
automobilistica a casa nostra c'è un 2 n
che ne va pazzo sono le battute a
memoria ma se mi mettessi a contarle
confrontando quelle pronunciate da
personaggi maschili e femminili
scoprirai che la maggior parte sono
assegnate ai maschietti che sono
comunque tutti i mezzi di trasporto ad
altre auto da corsa ai trattori e camion
i camper intersse 3 il terzo episodio
della saga
la prima versione del copione contava
bene il 90 per cento delle battute
assegnate ai personaggi maschili
lo sappiamo perché la mia calcolate con
precisione gesti kydd che lavora alla
disney pixar e di mestiere fa la
segretaria di edizione cioè la persona
che controlla tutte le sceneggiature
dopo aver notato quel numero spaventoso
ha cominciato a creare tabelle da
mostrare ai creativi durante la
produzione del film per migliorare così
la situazione e all'uscita del film la
proporzione era notevolmente cambiata
con un collega sviluppatore ha poi
realizzato un software per automatizzare
questi calcoli e oggi tutti i copioni di
tutti i film alla disney pixar vengono
analizzati per genere in ogni fase di
produzione in sol l'ultimo
lungometraggio si è arrivati alla
perfetta parità quando inizia a contare
anche quando si tratta di un cartone
animato succede questo
scopri una realtà di cui non ti era
accorta prima e magari puoi cambiarla in
meglio
ma torniamo ai miei dati mesi prima di
restare incinta per la seconda volta
avevo letto una statistica pubblicata
sulla voce.info sul fatto che le donne a
15 anni dalla maternità guadagnano quasi
6 mila euro
rispetto a chi non è mai diventato
genitore beh non è possibile a me non
succederà ho pensato io ho sempre molto
lavoro non rinuncio mai a niente
e infatti sono su questo palco
all'ottavo mese di gravidanza
il mio fatturato sarà rimasto lo stesso
negli anni ma quando mi sono decisa a
guardare i dati
ho fatto una scoperta dopo la nascita di
filippo il mio primo figlio il mio
fatturato era sceso notevolmente e
sebbene stia risalendo vite incrociate
per il 2021 sembra ancora lontano dal
tornare allo stesso livello del 2017
la mia situazione personale è una
conferma di quella nazionale
secondo i dati raccolti dal sito
openpolis
il tasso di occupazione delle madri e di
8 punti inferiore a quello delle donne
senza figli
ecco non solo una conferma ma sono
fortunata ad avere un lavoro
spero di non aver gettato nella
disperazione tutti i futuri genitori che
mi ascoltano perché le cose possono
cambiare
ce lo conferma il gender and quality
index di bloomberg un indice che misura
le performance delle aziende
dal punto di vista della trasparenza
nella divulgazione dei dati di genere le
aziende che raccolgono dati sulle
disparità di genere interna che iniziano
a contare poi investono sull'uguaglianza
nel 46 per cento dei casi offrono
sussidi finanziari per accedere ai
servizi dell'infanzia il 65 per cento ha
predisposto una falsa per l'uso del
tiralatte e più della metà il 52 per
cento è inserito un requisito di parità
per i ruoli di management
questo è il potere dei dati aiutarci a
identificare i problemi e risolverli ma
vi ricordate del nostro william edward
heming il manager che metteva in
contrasto dati e opinioni perché quello
che vi ho raccontato è sì molto
incoraggiante ma c'è un problema
raccogliere alcuni dati e non altri è
comunque una decisione
una scelta che non è neutra per
che siamo esseri umani quindi le scelte
sono sempre frutto della nostra storia
della nostra individualità del contesto
in cui ci troviamo
ebbene sì i dati hanno dei limiti non li
troviamo per strada già pronti all'uso
qualcuno deve produrli raccoglierli
analizzarli e pubblicarli
ed è anche compito della politica
scegliere dove investire perché venga
coperto un fenomeno o una situazione con
l'indagine statistica
quali sono i questi limiti dei dati è il
primo è l'errore umano perché per
raccoglierli spesso bisogna riportare al
computer numeri scritti su fogli di
carta inserire dati a mano in una cella
di un foglio di calcolo oppure ricordate
il mio viaggio in messico
banalmente io dovevo ricordarmi ogni
sera di caricare il mio braccialetto
conta parte nelle ore notturne
altrimenti avrei perso i dati del giorno
successivo il secondo limite dei dati i
nostri byas cioè gli automatismi mentali
che ci portano a prendere decisioni in
fretta e senza fatica ma a volte sono
basati su percezioni errate o deformate
su pregiudizi ideologie o suo interesse
personale
prima di diventare genitore avrei mai
pensato di analizzare i dati sul
rapporto tra donne maternità e lavoro
forse no il mio interesse personale mi
ha fatto notare una situazione che
riguarda altre donne
ma cosa mi sto perdendo prendendo in
considerazione solo il contesto in cui
vivo non considerando il mio privilegio
di donna bianca eterosessuale non
disabile istruita e con un lavoro terzo
limite affidarci ai dati come se
contenessero tutte le risposte
e invece sono solo un modo per avere
informazioni sul fenomeno non per forza
migliore di un altro o almeno non può
essere l'unico vi ricordate l'importanza
del contesto anche la raccolta di
testimonianze di
di interviste possono aiutare moltissimo
a completare il puzzle della situazione
in tutti gli ambiti c'è una soluzione a
questi limiti si può essere quella
dell'approccio del femminismo dei dati
che per prime hanno divulgato le docenti
ricercatrici delle menti di boston
catherine d'ignazio e lauren klein
attenzione quando parliamo di femminismo
non stiamo dicendo che riguarda
esclusivamente le donne o il genere
femminile anzi il femminismo dei dati è
intersezionale cioè vede le ingiustizie
e le forme di esclusione come il
sessismo il razzismo la xenofobia
l'omofobia la transfobia labili smo come
elementi interconnessi
il femminismo dei dati usa le pratiche
di raccolta analisi pulizia e
visualizzazione dei dati per sfidare
queste oppressioni a livello sistemico
considerando i limiti dei dati come
parte del processo con l'obiettivo di
avere una società più equa e inclusiva
rendendo espliciti questi limiti quindi
anche i nostri privilegi ei nostri byas
un esempio di femminismo dei dati è
creare squadre di data scientist e
designer che rispettino per esempio la
diversità della nostra società
oppure occuparsi di temi scomodi su cui
la politica non investe abbastanza dal
punto di vista della raccolta dati in
messico l'attivista marias alghero ha
cominciato a raccogliere da sola del
i dati sui casi dei femminicidi nel suo
paese diventando in poco tempo la fonte
più affidabile sul tema senza il suo
lavoro le storie di queste donne non
sarebbero mai state raccontate rimanendo
soltanto casi di cronaca nelle pagine
dei giornali
il femminismo dei dati usa i numeri ei
grafici per mostrare l'invisibile
soprattutto per mostrare come funzionano
il potere e il privilegio i pregiudizi
che abbiamo nella realizzazione di una
mappa o di una tabella ma anche nella
raccolta dati
il problema è umano non è
logico e questa è una buona notizia
perché anche io nel mio piccolo posso
contribuire a rivoluzionare il sistema
come non pensando che chi porta i dati
non abbia le sue opinioni le sue tesi da
portare avanti
mi dispiace william edward heming ma non
sono d'accordo con te e poi imparare a
leggere dati e grafici
con questa consapevolezza come ci invita
il titolo di questo evento festina lente
proviamo a non avere fretta davanti a
una notizia un'infografica ma anche un
messaggio fu a zapp che ci viene
condiviso e ci viene detto che è basato
sui dati solo perché contiene un numero
o una tabella verifichiamo le fonti
confrontiamo i punti di vista cercando
di scoprire qual è il motivo che ha
portato quell ente di ricerca quel
partito politico a raccogliere certi
dati quel giornale a divulgarli
quell'associazione a promuovere quei
numeri ed interesse pubblico oppure
serve per preparare nuove ingiustizie a
rafforzare il potere
i dati ci svelano l'invisibile ma serve
tutta la nostra attenzione perché ci
aiutino a cambiare il mondo in meglio
grazie
[Musica]